viruses are everywhere in plants birds
animals and in humans but most don't
stand a chance of adapting and spreading
the natural world's defense systems
fight them off and vaccines help as well
but every now and then a virus gets
through dumping the species barrier from
say a pig or a bird to target instead a
human coronaviruses are a large family
of viruses common in animals until the
end of last year just six were known to
infect people the Wuhan coronavirus is
number seven now four of these strains
cause illnesses like the common cold
unpleasant but for most of us not
life-threatening but the others are
killers the highly contagious severe
acute respiratory syndrome or SARS broke
out in China over 2002 into 2003 and it
killed almost 10 percent of those who
became infected it's thought to have
spread from the civet cat to humans
since the Middle East respiratory
syndrome MERS was identified in Saudi
Arabia in 2012 more than 850 people have
died if thoughts have come from the
camel now both have caused panic both
killed but both have been contained
this new strain is a killer - and can be
passed from human to human but although
it seems at this stage to be less
contagious panic is rising as it spreads
within China and across China's borders
- the threat of a global health
emergency looms